[Musique]
imaginez on estime que l'ensemble des
cyber fraude par téléphone par texto par
courriel aurait coûté environ 8
milliards de dollars aux canadiens de
2013 à 2017
il y a hobo mots des dizaines de
milliers victimes
la fraude amoureuse dans laquelle
quelqu'un établi un lien avec vous et
vous demande de l'argent si la plus
rentable pour les criminels mais celle
dont on parle le plus
en 2018 parce que tout le monde a reçu
cet appel c'est la fraude de l'agencé de
revenu du canada un criminel qui souvent
à l'étranger personnifie un employé de
l'agencé vous demande de rembourser des
impôts maintenant et ça presse
ceux qui sont les plus vulnérables face
à cette fraude les personnes âgées les
nouveaux arrivants les gens qui sont
isolées et ceux qui sont mal informés il
y en a peut-être dans votre entourage et
vous ne le savez peut-être même pas
parce qu'à peine 5 % des gens dénoncent
ce crime
alors prenez dont le risque d'être
impolis si vous recevez un appel d'un
organisme raccrocher vous pourrez
ensuite rappeler un numéro connu de
l'organisme en question mais d'abord et
avant tout accroché
[Musique]